Transcription: Marie PAVY
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
J'ai vraiment beaucoup de plaisir
à vous présenter cet objet.
C'est ma dernière trouvaille.
Elle est l'œuvre d'un artisan artiste.
Il a deux casquettes.
Il travaille au fin fond de la Bourgogne
et il collecte, il ramasse,
il récupère des vieux débris,
de camions, de voitures…
Bref, il crée.
Il crée quoi ? Il crée ça.
Alors, qu’est-ce que c’est, ça ?
Eh bien, vous voyez une ampoule,
c’est donc une lampe.
Cette ampoule est placée
dans une trompe de klaxon,
d’un avertisseur sonore.
Créatif!
Le corps central a été composé
de deux morceaux soudés.
Vous voyez de chaque côté des clignotants,
on appelle ça des flèches de direction,
des clignotants d’un ancien camion.
Et la base, c’est un pied
qui traînait au fond d’un hangar.
L’ensemble…
ça, ça peut être une lampe,
ça peut être une œuvre d’art,
ça peut être un personnage bien sympa,
ça peut être…
un résidu du monde industriel
qui n’existe plus,
et ça peut être ce que vous voulez.
Je vous laisse choisir la réponse à la
première question :
qu’est-ce que c’est?
À présent, il faut lui donner un nom,
un nom nouveau,
si possible un mot nouveau.
Il faut en créer
et j’en ai créé quelques-uns.
Le premier mot que j’ai créé pour vous,
c’est “métalampe”.
J’ai pris “métal”,
je suis allé chercher “lampe”.
“Métal” vient du latin “metallum”,
“lampe” vient du grec “lampas”.
Je les ai associés et le hasard des mots -
ce n’est pas sous ma volonté -
le hasard des mots a créé “métalampe”,
comme le métavers, comme la métaphysique.
En quelque sorte,
la lampe au-delà de la lampe,
presque la lampe du futur.
Savoureux!
Le deuxième mot que j’ai créé,
je ne l’ai pas créé.
“Cyclope” existe depuis
que les aventures d’Ulysse sont connues.
C’est Homère qui a créé ce mot,
onze siècles avant Jésus-Christ.
En revanche,
il n’avait certainement pas pensé
à ce type de cyclopes,
puisque chez Homère,
les Cyclopes sont des géants,
et là, c’est peut-être un géant,
mais d’une autre nature.
Et enfin le dernier…
mot que j’ai créé,
c’est un mot mélangé
d’anglais,
et de latin.
“Minimum”.
Tout petit.
Et “cop”.
Pardon pour les agents de police
qui sont peut-être dans la salle,
mais “cop”, ça veut dire le flic
en argot, donc c’est le petit flic.
Et je voudrais que vous m’aidiez
à choisir le mot parmi ces trois
qui d’après vous, correspond le mieux
à l’idée que vous vous faites
de cet objet.
Alors je vais vous demander
de lever la main sur le premier nom :
“métalampe”.
Merci de votre participation si spontanée.
“Cyclope”?
J'ai le droit de lever la main.
Nous sommes distancés pour l'instant.
Et enfin, “minicop” ?
Ah ! Eh bien écoutez
le palmarès est donné.
“Minicop” venait, j’ai oublié
de le dire, de “Robocop”,
une inspiration d’un film
que j’ai vu autrefois.
Alors “métalampe” l’emporte.
Tant mieux pour lui.
Je vous rassure.
Les trois noms, les trois mots nouveaux,
y compris le second
qui  est un néologisme de sens,
les trois noms nouveaux sont pertinents.
Pour une simple et bonne raison.
C’est que cet objet…
n’existe pas.
Donc je vous rassure, l’after c’est tout
à l’heure, je ne l’ai pas encore pris,
mais il n’existe pas,
il n’existe pas.
Qu’est-ce qui existe ?
C'est l'idée que vous vous en faites.
Un mot nouveau,
ce n’est pas juste un nouvel outil
dans une caisse à outils.
Un mot nouveau,
c’est une nouvelle idée qui fait commerce.
C'est une nouvelle idée en circulation.
Il se crée chaque année environ 150 mots
nouveaux qui entrent dans le dictionnaire.
Il s'en crée beaucoup plus.
Mais les lexicographes
qui créent les dictionnaires
attendent que l’usage
sanctionne les mots,
c’est-à-dire qu’ils soient en circulation.
Donc les mots nouveaux renvoient
à nos idées, à nos représentations.
Du coup, les mots nouveaux
parlent de nous.
Savez-vous pourquoi
j’ai choisi “cyclope”?
Eh bien parce que j’ai adoré,
je confesse,
j’ai adoré les histoires d’Ulysse
que j’ai eu la chance de pouvoir traduire
il y a bien longtemps,
mais ça a été une de mes passions.
Donc quand je l'appelle le cyclope,
cet objet est relié à moi.
Je l'aime beaucoup du coup.
Mais vous avez évidemment le droit
et la pertinence de choisir un autre nom
par rapport à vos représentations.
Ainsi, si les mots nouveaux
parlent de nous,
alors, on peut lire les 150 mots qui,
chaque année, entrent dans le dictionnaire
et se faire une idée de la société
dans laquelle nous vivons,
du temps qui passe,
des sociétés en transformation.
Par exemple, ce mot suivant :
“iel”, qui a fait couler tellement d’encre
alors qu’il n’a que… trois lettres,
il est bien frêle !
Et pourtant, il a un pouvoir détonnant !
C'est étonnant.
Pourquoi a-t-il ce pouvoir?
Eh bien parce que ouille ! ça fait mal !
Il décolle l’idée qu’on se fait
de l’humain.
De tout temps, un humain
est défini par sa catégorie,
féminin,
par son genre,
féminin ou masculin,
et non pas par autre chose.
Or, les humains qui ont décidé
de ne plus se définir eux-mêmes
comme étant binaires,
soit homme, soit femme, ont fait pression
pour créer ce pronom nouveau
composé de “il” et de “elle”,
- vous l’aviez compris, c’est une fusion -
afin de refuser la binarité.
C’est un combat de société.
C’est une transformation
sociologique mondiale.
Vous avez l’équivalent
en anglais : “they”.
Vous l’avez en allemand,
en italien, en espagnol.
Je ne connais évidemment
pas toutes les langues du monde,
mais j’ai fait suffisamment
de vérifications pour m’en assurer.
Ce mouvement est mondial.
Il est en train de nous faire prendre
conscience que la binarité
n’est pas la seule réponse
pour définir et répondre à une question
qui a au moins 2000 ans ou 3000 ans,
depuis qu’on a des traces d’écriture,
soit un homme, soit une femme.
Ainsi, ces mots nouveaux existent.
D’abord parce qu’il faut bien
nommer ces objets.
Nous innovons sans cesse, nous créons,
les artistes, mais nous innovons,
nous innovons technologiquement,
nous innovons avec les algues,
nous innovons dans la cuisine,
nous innovons dans la cybersexualité.
Vraiment, nous ne cessons d’innover
et donc il faut trouver
les mots pour le dire.
Mais il est une direction bien plus
intéressante d'après moi et très étrange.
C’est qu’il est tout à fait
possible pour un mot
de précéder la réalité
à laquelle il renvoie.
C'est tout à fait surprenant.
Un mot peut préfigurer le futur,
c’est-à-dire qu’un mot peut être créé
alors que la chose à laquelle il renvoie
n’existe pas encore.
On peut prendre
un  premier exemple très simple,
et ce premier exemple
vient de Rabelais.
Rabelais écrit en 1534 “Pantagruel”,
dans lequel Gargantua, le géant, s’amuse
avec son coach, on dirait aujourd’hui,
et il s’amuse à fabriquer des automates.
Il faut attendre
deux siècles, 1738,
pour voir le premier automate être créé.
Deux cents ans avant,
l’artiste l’avait imaginé.
On a encore de très nombreux exemples,
en 1921, Karel Čapek, l’auteur tchèque,
qui écrit une pièce
de théâtre avec des robots.
Je vous recommande absolument la lecture
de ce livre qui a plus de 100 ans.
Eh bien, il faut attendre 1951,
trente ans plus tard,
pour voir le premier robot apparaître,
et enfin,
j’en arrêterai là, c’est un exemple
qui m’a touché personnellement :
En 1992, je lis la bande dessinée
d’Enki Bilal, “Froid équateur”,
dans laquelle un sport nouveau apparaît.
Je lis ça d’une manière
désintéressée, je dirais.
C’est un mélange de jeu d’échecs,
de “chess” en anglais, et de boxe,
le “chessboxing”.
Et voici qu’en 2003, le premier combat
de chessboxing est organisé
par un lecteur fan
de Bilal
Est-ce que seuls les artistes
ont la possibilité
de préfigurer le monde de demain?
On sait très bien que les artistes font
commerce d'imaginaire et d'imagination.
On sait très bien qu’ils ont
cette capacité créative à imaginer,
comme on l’a entendu
aujourd’hui, des utopies,
voire des utopies
qui tournent mal, des dystopies.
Et ainsi, les mots
sont leur matière première.
Pourtant, nous sommes nous aussi,
nous qui ne sommes pas forcément artistes,
en mesure de créer des mots
nouveaux pour fabriquer le futur.
Nous pensons que le futur se fabrique
uniquement par l’innovation,
par exemple technologique,
par l’innovation sociale,
l’innovation politique,
par des nouvelles émotions
qu’on arrive à nommer.
J’ai entendu parler d’écoanxiété
durant cette soirée formidable.
Bref, on pense que les mots
ne font pas partie de la fête créative.
Je ne le crois pas.
Cet été, nous avons eu
des vagues de chaleur intenses
dans de très nombreuses régions du monde.
La ville de Séville appartient
à un mouvement qui s’appelle
“Name the Wave”.
Nommons les vagues de chaleur
et pour la première fois dans l’Histoire,
la vague de chaleur qui a fait
beaucoup de morts, vous le savez,
la vague de chaleur de cet été
qui s’est abattuesur le sud de l’Espagne
a été nommée par la ville de Séville.
Et nos amis de Séville
n’ont pas trouvé mieux
que de l’appeler Zoé.
Je suis vraiment désolé
s’il y a des Zoé dans la salle.
Ils ont procédé par analogie
avec la façon que nous avons
de nommer les ouragans.
Vous savez que depuis plus de 50 ans,
on nomme les ouragans.
Alors le dessinateur Kuper
a même eu l’idée
d’en faire déjà un de ses dessins.
Il participait, il a contribué à Charlie
Hebdo pendant plusieurs mois
et il l’a, lui, appelé
le petit Michel, Mitch.
Donc les Zoé,
les petits Michel dans la salle,
nous sommes bien servis.
À quoi ça sert de nommer
une vague de chaleur ?
Est-ce bien nécessaire
ou est-ce un travers
de notre “société de com’“.
En tant que passionné de mots et créateur
de mots, évidemment, je n'y crois pas.
Je pense que nommer,
c’est d’abord définir.
Pour définir, catégoriser,
de quoi s’agit-il,
il faut comprendre,
comprendre permet de connaître.
Et lorsque l’on connaît, scientifiquement
ou intuitivement ou émotionnellement,
la connaissance n’est pas forcément
un long chemin.
Lorsque l’on connaît,
eh bien, on peut anticiper.
Les vagues de chaleur font 50 000 morts
chaque année dans le monde.
Nommer une vague de chaleur
peut influencer nos comportements.
Le langage peut créer des comportements
qui n’existent pas encore,
des comportements qui consistent
à se prémunir et à faire attention.
Donc on voit bien à travers
ces quelques exemples,
qu’en matière de langage,
on fait du neuf avec du vieux.
C'est très mal vu dans certains domaines,
mais en langage, tout est possible.
Les bonnes soupes dans les vieux pots,
vous connaissez la formule.
On va prendre quelques exemples
et on va voir d’où ils viennent.
J’aime beaucoup le dernier album
de Stromae, dans lequel le second…
la seconde chanson
s’appelle La Solassitude.
Vous avez compris comment
la “solassitude” est créée.
La lassitude…
de la… vous l’avez trouvé
comme moi, de la solitude.
On fusionne deux mots.
Prenons encore quelques exemples.
J’aime beaucoup les mots en –isme,
ce sont des concepts.
Un mot qui se termine en –isme
est toujours une conceptualisation
de situation réelle qui existe
pour prendre de la hauteur
et  embrasser l’ensemble
des circonstances.
Et voici qu’en Wallonie, on a nommé
le changement politique :
“Dégagisme”.
La valse des gouvernements,
la valse des premiers ministres,
une première ministre vient
de démissionner la semaine dernière,
se dit aujourd’hui, d’une manière
un peu franche, on dirait un peu cash.
Un autre mot, si jamais ce soir
vous abusez lors de l’after,
eh bien peut-être que vous aurez un malus,
voici le latin qui revient,
le latin qu’on n’enseigne plus,
mais qui est extraordinairement vivant.
Le grec qu’on enseigne encore moins,
et qui continue de vivre
dans les mots nouveaux.
Et voici que vous pouvez
devenir “malussé“.
Ces mots sont officiellement
dans les dictionnaires,
et la semaine dernière,
nous avons entendu parler
des mots qui entreront
dans le dictionnaire de 2023.
Alors parfois,
il faut une lecture persistante.
Il faut prêter attention à ces mots
qui ne sont pas des outils triviaux.
Ils recèlent des trésors.
Ainsi, le mot révolution,
qui est très ancien,
il date du début du Moyen âge,
dans lequel se cache
une nouvelle forme de mobilité
qui peut vous faire grincer des dents.
Sauf si vous êtes du bon côté.
Car dans “révolution”,
qu’est-ce qu’on trouve?
La “vélorution”.
Il suffisait de permuter les lettres,
de donner un coup de Rubik's cube.
Le langage, c'est aussi s'amuser
avec les lettres.
Le langage a un principe d’économie.
Le langage a un principe de recyclabilité.
On prend du latin, du grec, de l’anglais,
du japonais, du wolof, de l’espagnol.
On mélange tout ça.
Tout est recyclé dans le langage.
On a un exemple extraordinaire
sous les yeux
de ce qu’on peut faire
avec du recyclé.
Et puis, on pourrait continuer.
J’aime beaucoup “Où est Charlie ?“.
Et où est Charlie en terme
de définition de son identité ?
Pas simple.
C’est un livre, trait d’union, jeu.
J.E.U.
C’est-à-dire un livre avec des pages
et en même temps un jeu,
un livre jeu.
Voici une identité hybride supplémentaire.
Les innovations
sont très souvent hybrides,
d’où la difficulté
que nous avons à les nommer.
Mais le langage recèle plus d'un talent.
Et voici qu’un chef d’entreprise
vivant en Bourgogne
et créant sa société
de fabrication de pansements
se demandait comment évoquer
les bienfaits de ses produits
et en fixant attentivement
ces quelques lettres,
le nom de sa région,
il découvrit qu’au centre de ce mot,
le centre de ce nom régional,
figurait exactement l’idée
qu’il voulait faire passer.
Vous avez trouvé “urgo” qui vient
“d’urgogne” et pas “d’urgence”.
C'est un heureux hasard.
Alors une dernière technique
et elle est très simple,
quand on n’arrive plus à définir cela,
à répondre à la question
“qu’est-ce que c’est?”
derrière un ‘comment ça s’appelle’,
il y a toujours un ‘qu’est-ce que c’est’,
Quand on n’y arrive plus,
on fait une pirouette et on s’échappe.
On s'échappe par la poésie par exemple,
on fait une image.
Et j’ai adoré ce mot qui est sorti,
que vous trouvez
dans les grands magasins de bricolage,
on va le voir s’afficher.
Il commence par “Ni ni”
et je suis sûr que vous savez compléter.
J’ai entendu “ni clou ni vis”.
Il s’agit d’une colle polymère
bicomposant,
sans solvant et sans odeur.
Finalement, savoir qu’on n’a besoin
ni d’un marteau ni d’une perceuse
sera plus aisé et plus facile à mémoriser.
Le langage est
une grande leçon d’économie.
Les mots nous apprennent à faire bref,
les mots nous apprennent
à faire beaucoup avec peu.
La plupart de ces mots nouveaux,
quand on les observe attentivement,
viennent pour 40% d’entre eux
d’emprunts à des langues étrangères.
Cette année, dans le dictionnaire
qui sortira en 2023,
ont été sélectionnés 150 mots,
dont à peu près 40% viennent
de ces emprunts à des langues étrangères,
et l’anglais représente 16% des 40%.
Ainsi, nous ne sommes pas inféodés
ni colonisés par les anglicismes,
ni par la culture de l’oncle Sam.
C'est une erreur chiffrée.
En revanche, nous en avons la perception
et pour autant la langue française
additionnée à la création des pays
francophones,
il y a plus de 300 millions
d’habitants au monde
qui parlent la langue française
à leur façon,
qui la travaille et qui la créée.
Le Québec, la Suisse,
la Belgique francophone,
de nombreux pays d’Afrique
représentent 60%.
Ainsi, notre langue fondée elle-même
sur du latin, sur du grec,
sur des emprunts à de l’allemand,
sur des emprunts
à d’autres langues étrangères,
notre langue est extrêmement vivante.
Alors…
tous ces mots nouveaux vont-ils survivre?
Quel est leur destin, en quelque sorte?
Eh bien, il en est des mots nouveaux
comme il en est des virus :
ils se propagent.
Et c’est vous, les propagatrices
et les propagateurs.
C’est vous qui donnez vie
à ces mots nouveaux ou pas.
J’ai entendu tout à l’heure
que vous donniez vie à “métalampe”
et tant mieux pour lui.
Ainsi, regardez, nous avons
la recommandation de l’Académie française
de parler de mot-clic et de mot-dièse,
qui sont des définitions
extrêmement précises,
et je dirais même assez élégantes.
Mais vous préférez parler
de hashtag, vraiment?
Vous préférez les anglicismes?
Pour une raison très simple,
c’est que la communauté mondiale
qui utilise le mot “hashtag”
est plus importante
que celle qui utilisera jamais
“mot-clic” ou “mot-dièse”.
Mais en matière de langage,
les deux sont possibles.
Le langage, c’est une grande leçon
de modestie, d’humilité,
parce que l’ambivalence est possible.
Pour finir, je voudrais terminer
sur un mot que j’ai créé facilement,
je vous l’accorde.
Je réfléchissais sur cette question
du pouvoir des mots nouveaux,
et par hasard,
je me rends compte que la définition
“pouvoir des mots”
est très, très proche
de “pouvoir du peuple”
qui est la définition étymologique du mot
que vous allez voir s’afficher à l’écran.
Je vous laisse méditer sur ce mot
de façon à ce que nous soyons bien
conscientes et conscients que les mots
ne sont pas simplement des outils
qui s’additionnent
dans une boîte à outils.
Ce sont des témoins
de la liberté d’expression
sans laquelle nous n’innoverions pas
et sans laquelle nous ne pourrions pas
créer de mots nouveaux.
Et le voici.
[Démotscratie]
(Applaudissements)